desde julio este gasoducto opera solo al
20% de su capacidad pero el miércoles se
detendrá por completo durante tres días
su segunda interrupción en los últimos
meses el nord stream 1 es una de las
principales conexiones que transporta
gas ruso a europa pero recientemente
entrega mucho menos de su capacidad
moscú asegura que el apagón se debe a
problemas de mantenimiento y culpa a las
sanciones occidentales
rusia estaba y sigue preparada para
cumplir con sus obligaciones europa
canadá reino unido eeuu y otros han
impuesto sanciones que no permiten el
trabajo de mantenimiento y reparación
normal
los líderes europeos sin embargo creen
que la situación tiene un trasfondo
político aloft 'carmo' la uis utilize
logias a rusia está usando el gas como
un arma de guerra tenemos que
prepararnos para el peor escenario que
sería un cese completo de sus envíos la
ministra de energía francesa habló así
el mismo día que gazprom paró su
distribución a angy la principal empresa
de gas francesa por unas disputas de
contrato parís ha asegurado a los
consumidores que hay reservas de gas
para dos meses de cara al invierno
aunque se podrían llegar a necesitar
medidas de racionamiento
alemania también se esfuerza en llenar
sus reservas de gas y aunque berlín va
adelantado a europa le siguen faltando
proveedores alternativos
antes de la guerra en ucrania rusia
proporcionaba el 40% del gas del 'viejo
continente'
ahora la unión europea buscan nuevas
fuentes como el norte de áfrica o medio
oriente además de envíos de gas líquido
a instalaciones especializadas
bruselas también quiere reformar la
política energética para separar los
precios de la electricidad de la
volatilidad del mercado del gas